[Music]
time now for a special holiday edition
of morning rounds this week a
prescription for holiday gifts with an
emphasis on health and wellness here to
share some of his top holiday picks a
CBS News medical contributor dr. David
agus doctor good morning I see we have a
theme here relating to sleep and there
are countless studies of course that say
it's not just the quantity of sleep but
also the quantity so is there anything
here that can help you track your sleep
and how important is that it's great but
first of all they're not all obviously
the book is not meant to put you so this
is a device under your mattress and it's
plugged into your wall and then what it
does is it monitors your heart rate your
sleep how deep it is all night and so I
use then I started to see I have two
glasses of wine I don't sleep as well
and this deep I'm stressed I don't sleep
as well I've actually changed my
behavior about having this under the bed
and the cool thing is you don't have to
charge it and do whatever it's always
there you know these are Bo's in the ear
headsets what they do is for the first
20 30 minutes of sleep you program it to
white noise the ocean or something that
puts you to sleep and then it's quiet
into Bloxx noise because you can't have
noise all night or your brain never gets
the quiet it needs to regenerate and so
this does it for the first 20 minutes it
allows you to sleep deep and they're
comfortable I mean because sometimes I
guess you have something in your ears
you're not really wanting them to be
there all night and you can't fall
asleep some people don't like anything
these are small and deep and cushioned
and so for me they actually work I was
shocked how well they worked okay what
about access
I'm looking sort of here towards the
foot where we think socks when we think
Christmas or Hanukkah you might get but
this is a little bit different and this
might actually help yes I want you to
sleep with these on so this is believe
it or not dr. Scholl's and with your
iPhone they take pictures of your foot
in all different positions then it goes
into a computer and 3d prints support
for your feet and they're personalized
actually my name is on it and you get it
a week later in the mail and you put it
in your shoes and it makes you actually
stand in a straighter position helps
your knees in your hip when you walk you
know they ask 80
what are the two things you would have
done differently in your life and health
number one was take better care of my
teeth and number two better care of my
feet affordable custom orthotics that
you can buy for someone that's what's so
cool is that these are inexpensive and
your doctor may have done hundreds of
these well they're doing millions of
these so there's a lot of data that they
work what's the price point I basically
I'm I me and the ear and the ear buds
because I got a firetruck that lives
across it I could actually use something
like that there you know in that kind of
$200 range yeah they're expensive
they're expensive but sleepsleep could
be worth a penny sleep is priceless
[Laughter]
I'm getting ideas I'm looking at this
blanket here because I love sleeping
with a heavy blanket what does this
provide well there's data that a heavy
blanket actually makes you release
hormones that makes you feel happier and
better and so you feel kind of more
content in your line they're almost
wound like with this blanket and because
it's weighted it's not too heavy and hot
it actually makes you feel better when
you sleep and there's a big trend to
using them now if Thundershirt for
humans and how about dust Stephen
Hawking's book here Steve and I had the
privilege of working with for a little
while as a remarkable man and this is
his family put together the answers are
the questions that everybody asks them
is there a god what will a AI artificial
intelligence do to our society you know
artists their life living in space all
of these answers are here and you know
to me it's I want you to stimulate your
brain during the holidays don't just sit
back and have a drink I want you
actually push yourself and these are the
questions that are deep within us we all
have these and I want you to think about
them and so a book like this actually
pushes that what kind of blanky that's
all I mean that's all you need maybe a
cup of hot cocoa
and good feet dr. agus thank you very
much